[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
قيل لي إلى حد الغثيان أن هذه
الموسيقى جزء من الروح البرتغالية ،
والآن تخيلت امرأة في سن معينة
ترتدي فستانًا أسود عتيقًا تصيح
في الزاوية ولكن ليس هذا الإصدار
[موسيقى]
لقد تحركت  هنا لأنني جئت لأغني في
مطعم أب وفي هذا الشارع على
سبيل المثال أتذكر أنك كنت تمشي
في الشارع وستستمع
لوالدك وهو يخرج من النوافذ كما لو أن
أحدهم يغني واحدًا آخر هنا وكان الأمر
كما لو كنت تمشي و  كان الأمر
كما لو كنت في منتصف الفهم
حقًا ،
جيزيلا تشاو بعيدة كل البعد عن
الصورة النمطية كما يمكنك أن تتخيل
شابًا نابضًا بالحياة وليس فستانًا أسود في
الأفق ، فلماذا يجب أن أرتدي كفتاة
نشأت في الأربعينيات أو في  الخمسينيات
ليس من
أنا ، أليس كذلك لأنني أحب
الشعر الذي يجب أن أتصرف كما
اعتادت جدتي أن تتصرف عندما كانت في
عمري ،
لذا فأين أكون في
مزارع ومزارع حديث هو حقًا أحياء قوية حقًا
الكاريزما التقليدية  أول سرير
يمكننا أن نقول يا فادو ، فما
هو الأب والأبسط هو الشعر
والتفكير بشكل جيد ، لقد فهمت
ذلك نوعًا ما يشبه
القول إن لوحة الموناليزا هي صورة أه
ما هو أكثر صدق مثل  يمكننا أن
نعبر عن شخصية البرتغاليين
البلد البرتغالي ،
حسنًا ، هذا فقط يطرح السؤال:
ما هي شخصية البرتغاليين
المكثفون ، ما هو الأشخاص المكثفون الذين لا
يحزنون كما يعتقد الكثير من الناس
عندما قلت لك جيدًا لماذا فاردو
حزين فقط أعني  الجميع يقول إنه أمر محزن
ومحزن ،
ما قلته لي ،
قلت إنه لا تخلط بين
الحزن الشديد
والشدة ، أعتقد أن الصورة هي تعبير يبدو وكأنه استمرار لـ Life Gizelle
يمكن أن تجد Fardo في أي مكان يبحث دائمًا
عن Echo
um
الشيء الذي لا
يمكنك رؤيته أنت لا تختار الأب الذي
اختاره لك إذا قرأت أي شيء عن
الأب
فهو يتحدث فقط عن شعر حزن حزين
ولكن هذا يعتمد عليك
في الطريقة التي تقرأ بها ذلك حقًا
تعني القصيدة الجميلة القصيدة التي يمكن أن تتحدث
عن حياة الجميع وهي
قصيدة يمكن أن تعيش عبر الزمن
لأنها ستتردد دائمًا داخل الناس ،
لذلك عندما أغني أشعر أنني
أستطيع التعبير عن نفسي
[موسيقى]
ما يجعل Fardo فريدًا  البرتغاليون ،
نحن حقًا ، نحن
مكثفون حقًا ، نحن أشخاص مكثفون حقًا ،
نحن نهتم كثيرًا ،
ونفكر بشدة في طريقة العيش ،
يمكنك أن تشعر أنه بطريقة
دراماتيكية نحن مسرحيون أيضًا ، هل أنت
درامي ، نعم ، لم أكن لأخمن أبدًا
لا
[ضحك]
أنا أقول أبي
[موسيقى]
أجنبي